let's see if you can tackle a more
complicated partial fraction
decomposition problem I have 10x squared
plus 12x plus 20 all of that over X to
the 3rd minus 8 the first thing to do
with any of these fried these rational
expressions that you want to I guess
decompose is to just make sure that the
numerator is of a lower degree than the
denominator and if it's not then you
just do the the algebraic long division
like we did in the first video but here
you can do from expection the highest
degree term here is the second degree
term here it's a third degree term so
we're cool
this is a lower degree than that one if
it was the same or higher we would do a
little long division the next thing to
do if we're going to decompose this is
into its components we have to figure
out the factors of the denominator right
here so that we can you know use those
factors as the denominators in each of
the components and a third degree
polynomial is much much much harder to
factor than a second degree polynomial
normally but this case there's something
should hopefully pop out at you if it
doesn't immediately hopefully what I'm
about to say will make it pop out at you
in the future you should always think
about what number when you substitute
into a into a into a polynomial will
make it equal to zero and in this case
you say well what to the third power
minus 8 equals zero and hopefully two
pops out at you and this is something
you can only do really through
inspection or through experience and you
remedial C to the third minus 8 is 0 so
2 is a zero of this so 2 is zero or two
makes this expression zero and that
tells us that X minus 2 is a factor so
we can rewrite this right here as 10 x
squared plus 12x plus 20 over X minus 2
times something something something
something we don't know what that
something is yet and I just want to hit
the point home with why this is true or
what the intuition by it is true if two
makes is this 0 2 should also make the
factored expression 0 and we know that 2
would make this factored expression 0
because when you put a 2 right here this
this factor becomes zero so it'll make
the whole thing zero and so that's why
that's the intuition where if you
substitute a number here it makes this
zero you do X minus that number here and
we know that that will be a factor of
the thing well anyway the next step if
we really want to want to decompose this
rational expression is to figure out
what this part of it is and the way to
do that is with algebraic long division
we essentially just divide X minus 2
into X to the third minus eight to get
this so let's do that so you get X minus
two goes into X to the third and
actually what I'm going to do is I'm
going to write I leave space for the
second degree term which is zero the
first degree term and then minus eight
is a constant term so minus eight I like
to put all my all my degree terms and
they're appropriate columns well you
don't have to when you do algebraic long
division so X minus two goes into X to
the third or X goes into X to the third
how many times you just have to look at
the highest degree terms what goes into
it x squared times I'll put it in the x
squared column x squared times X minus
two x squared times X is X to the third
x squared times minus 2 is minus two x
squared and now we want to subtract that
from that so I could just or I could add
the negative I always find that easier
so these cancel out so I'm left with two
x squared minus eight how many times is
X minus two go into two x squared minus
eight you just look at the highest
degree terms X goes into 2x squared 2x
times so plus 2x 2x times X is 2x
squared 2x times minus 2 is minus 4x
subtract that from that so we can or we
could just add the negative and then we
have 4x minus 8x goes into 4 X 4 times 4
times X minus 2 is 4x minus 8 and
there's no remainder and this is further
confirmation
x- to definitely was a factor of x 2/3
minus 8 and the other factor is this
right here x squared plus 2x plus 4
times X minus 2 is equal to X to the
third minus 8 so now we can write our
original problem we can write our
original problem like actually let me
write well I did let me write it down
let me write it down here what was it it
was 10 let me switch to another color it
was 10 x squared I have a bad memory
plus 12 X plus 20 plus 12 X plus 20 over
X minus 2 times what was that x squared
plus 2 X plus 4 x squared plus 2 X plus
4 so all the work we did so far is just
to just to factor out that X to the
third minus 8 but now we can actually do
some partial fraction expansion or
partial fraction decomposition so this
is going to be equal to and this is the
interesting point this is where we
diverge or advanced a little bit from
what we did in the first video this is
going to be equal to a constant over
this denominator over X minus 2 plus and
this is a little different than what
you're going to see when you saw in the
last video plus an X term some
coefficient times an X term plus C so BX
plus C over this x squared plus 2x plus
4 and you might say Sal how did you know
to do that well what you do is you look
at the degree of the denominator this is
a first-degree denominator and you say
okay the degree of the numerator and the
in the this this part of the fraction I
guess you could call it it's going to be
1 less than that so this first degree
since it's going to be a zero degree or
a constant term here the degree is 2
right the degree is 2 so the degree of
its numerator is going to be 1 and since
this degree is 1 it could still have a
constant term which is a zero degree
term so you get BX plus C and you know
maybe maybe it does end up just being a
constant in which case we can solve for
B and it'll just be 0 actually there's
another thing you might be asking is
like hey why don't we factor this
further and
you can try but if you look at it by
inspection you could kind of in your
head do the quadratic formula and you'll
see that you'll only get imaginary roots
here so this actually isn't more
this isn't factorable in the reals
anymore there are no more real zeros to
this so we we have factored this as much
as we can so the key now to complete our
partial fraction expansion is to just
solve for the a B's and C's and we'll do
it exactly the same way we did in the
last video so if we just so what we want
to do is essentially add these two
things
so if we add let me write this on the
left hand side so 10x squared plus 12x
plus 20 over X minus 2 times x squared
plus 2x plus 4 is equal to if we add
these two things we want to get a common
denominator which is X minus 2 times x
squared plus 2x plus 4 just multiply the
two things and then that'll be if when
we add the comment then it's a times
this x squared plus 2x plus 4 plus bx
plus c bx plus c times this times X
minus 2 well the denominators are the
same so the numerators have to equal
each other so we have I'll rewrite it
10x squared plus 12x plus 20 is equal to
a times x squared plus 2x plus 4 plus BX
plus C all of that times X minus 2 this
is a might look like a hairy problem and
if you do it kind of the slow way that I
do in the last video would take you
forever it would be three equations and
three unknowns very very hairy but we
can do is a system oh pretty much the
same way we did it the first one let's
pick X values that simplify this and
allow us to solve for one of these a B
or CS at a time and the immediate thing
is well what can i what x value can I
substitute that will cancel out this at
least two of the variables two of them a
B or C and if I put X is equal to two
then this thing becomes zero which will
make this whole expression zero and I'll
just be left with an A and the X's which
I'll know is 2 because I'm picking X to
be equal to so let's do that so if X is
equal to 2 X is equal to 2 then what do
I get I get 10 x squared so I get 10
times 4 all right that's 2 squared plus
12 times 2 which is 24 plus 20 is equal
to a times 2 squared is 4 plus 4 plus 4
and then all of this just becomes 0
right because I picked X is equal to 2
so this is what 10 times 4 is 40 plus 44
that's 84 is equal to 12 a divide both
sides by 12 we get a is equal to 7 we're
making progress all right so now let's
see we know what a is can we pick any
other x values that will make the B
disappear or the C well we can make the
B disappear if we make X is equal to 0
so let's try that out
so if we say let me pick a new vibrant
color if we yellow if we make X equal to
0 then the left-hand side of this this
is 0 0 we just left with where's
yourself with 20 is equal to a which is
just 7 times 0 plus 0 plus 4 7 times 4
plus BX plus C the BX just disappears
because B times 0 is 0 plus C times 0
minus 2 C times minus 2
scroll down a little bit so we get 20 is
equal to 28 minus 2c subtract 28 from
both sides minus 8 is equal to minus 2 C
C is equal to 4 we're almost done now
let me rewrite our equation up here so
we with the A's and the let me see if I
can do this all right so now I have 10 x
squared plus 12x plus 20 is equal to
7/7 times x squared plus 2x plus 4 plus
B X plus C is 4 times X minus 2 almost
ran out of space so now we have X's and
B so to solve for B we can really just
substitute any value of x that makes our
math reasonably easy that doesn't make
the B disappear so we can't pick X is
equal to zero but a good number is 1 so
if X is equal to 1 we have 10 plus 12
plus 20 is equal to 7 times 1 plus 2
plus 4 that's 7 plus B times 1 is just B
plus 4 times 1 minus 2 is minus 1 so
this is 22 42 is equal to 49 minus B
minus 4z you can let's see I don't want
to mess up the math so we can say 42 is
equal to 45 minus B subtract 45 from
both sides you get minus 3 is equal to
minus B and you get B is equal to 3
divide both sides by minus 1 and so our
original problem up here we now know
that B is equal to 3 C was equal to 4 C
is equal to 4 and a is equal to 7 so the
partial fraction decomposition of this
we're now done is 7 over X minus 2 plus
3 X plus 4 over x squared plus 2x plus 4
well that was a pretty tiring problem
and you can see the partial fraction
decomposition becomes a lot more
complicated when you have higher degree
denominators but hopefully you found
that a little bit useful